our family is still desperate for
answers after their son was shot and
killed while hanging out with friends
happened in early January on Tropicana
near Eastern they spoke with Victoria
Saha because they need your help to
figure out who did this
[Music]
the Sanchez family is back where their
son took his last breath I'm looking at
this place
not in I'm helpless
Isaiah Sanchez says his 18 year old son
Christopher was spending the night with
friends at the Toscana Apartments I sent
him a text at 9 30 in night I told him
to get back home in the early morning
hours of January 9th Christopher was
last seen spray painting The Walls by
the complex while assius and his wife
Marie don't condone what their son was
doing they say it wasn't a reason to be
shot she's only 18.
my heart is broken
Christopher's body was found right here
by the washes near Tropicana and topaz
Metro Police released new videos showing
the moments those shots were fired and
it could have been taken by someone
living in those apartments
the amount of Shadow were fired someone
knows something it's been almost two
months since Christopher's life was
taken but his family is moving their
focus from grief to Justice well I wake
up in the middle of the night
now cry
I go to the cemetery
can you help it which is why they
reached out to Crime Stoppers of Nevada
crimes have solved a lot faster when
there's Community involvement all I'm
asking the the communities to say
something
they come forward you know something
please
if you know anything about the shooting
you are asked to please call Crime
Stoppers
702-385-555 you can remain anonymous and
you could get a reward for your tip